good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 3990 for object
class quatre special containment
procedures SCP thirty-nine 94 is
currently being held on site at site 92
the doors to SCP 39 94 s containment
chambers must be pressurized as to
prevent instances from maneuvering
through gaps between the door and its
frame instances are to be separated by
category into their respective
containment chambers in groups no more
than 15 perch aim bur should the number
of instances in any given category
exceed 800 termination of up to 500
instances may be permitted termination
of an instance of scp-3467 Stinson occur
bimonthly the foundation web crawlers
must consistently monitor upcoming
meteor showers and databases of medical
facilities in order to track uncontained
instances of scp-3467 Aksum 'm of three
times daily with foundation generated or
heavily altered media see addendum 3 all
media is to be said
human activity and regarded as
acceptable behavior for humans
regardless of the nature of the content
incoming information from outside
instances or sources must be immediately
substituted with a fur mentioned media
all personnel who interact with any
aspect of SCP 39 94 or files regarding
it must undergo a blood test prior to
entering and exiting the containment
chamber as to prevent allowing the
incorrect personnel from exiting
description SCP 39 94 is the collective
designation for a cluster of
extraterrestrial entities currently
consisting of SCP 39 94 a1 through SCP
39 94 see instances of scp-3467
be having any amount of shell decay but
with a retained shell and sea lacking
any show SCP 39 94 develops and inhabits
outer skins hence for referred to as
shells that resemble human beings a SCP
39 94 will favour mimicking the
appearance of a pre-existing individual
in its immediate vicinity if it lacks a
shell if no human is present shell
formation will occur regardless these
shells are assumed to act as disguises
to hide the inner form of SCP 39 94 mud
off tinfoil to perform as intended 68%
of attempts by SCP 39 94 to form
humanoid shells have resulted in various
deformities including but not limited to
twisted appendages severe malformation
resembling elephantitis disproportionate
skeletal structure and
the interior composition of SCP 39 94 is
of an unknown viscous substance without
a shell the bonnie's of SCP 39 94 lack
any confined form or structure and may
have a height upwards of five hundred
and sixty centimeters in this state SCP
thirty-nine 94 maneuvers by dragging
itself across a surface using any number
of its limbs thirty-eight percent of
conversations held between foundation
personnel and instances of scp-3467 as
displayed symptoms in line with those of
speech and communication disorders
notably cluttering and apraxia of speech
instances under foundation custody have
shown to be adapting rapidly to match
the language proficiency of personnel
countermeasures have been implemented to
combat this see addendum three discovery
initial discovery of SCP thirty-nine 94
occurred after new stations in Bolivia
Germany and Madagascar reported dozens
of wild animals having been shred to
pieces with pulpy viscous innards of a
solid uniform color samples taken from
deceased instances proved to be
extraterrestrial with no known relatives
living on earth several days prior to
the initial discovery all three cities
had experienced a minor meteor shower
meteorites retrieved near recovery
locations have tested positive for DNA
samples of SCP 39 94 implying that SCP
39 94 has been utilizing meteorites as a
method of travel from their location of
origin
addendum 1 on January 6th three of the
total B category instances of scp-3467
the shell testing suggests that shell
decay is a natural process with signs
beginning one to four months after the
shell is initially formed and dissolving
entirely within one year the process of
Shale formation takes a maximum of three
days and there is no known way to
inhibit this process interview log a1
interviewed SCP 3990 for a7 interviewer
dr. Kaufmann for word SCP 39 94 a7 was
recovered from Ireland three days prior
to the interview as CP 39 94 a7 was
recorded to have been initially
disregarded as an intoxicated
townsperson
until it was seen to have snapped its
elbows back in half and kept going about
its business once it was administered
medical treatment
hospital staff discovered that SCP 39 94
a7 lacked any human bodily fluids and
the foundation was subsequently involved
playing log no no breakfast in time for
breakfast are you
[Music]
you say poverty for breakfast you know
what waffle is åsa
high SCP 39 94 a seven pauses briefly it
gazes distantly then clears its throat
the following lines from SCP 39 94 a
seven contained several words of
Argentinean Spanish which have been
translated into English closing
statement dr. Kaufman's interview with
SCP 39 94 a7 has led to the discovery of
telepathic communications existing
between instances of scp-3467 cover
instances of scp-3467 log 4 on August 12
2014 a security breach was attempted by
SCP 39 94 a 7 a 24 a 33 B 3 B 78 C 16
and C 27 C 16 NC 27 provided aid to the
breach by pressing themselves between
the crevices of the containment chamber
door and the door frame to forcibly
unhinge the door
they then functioned as a distraction by
blocking off guards from accessing one
side of the hallway leading to scp-3467
s mass in order to surpass them into the
hallway remaining instances of scp-3467
taken from each other's uniforms the
group of a category instances acted in
the roles of personnel escorting wounded
researchers to the medical Bay the
security breach lasted a total of 23
minutes before all violating instances
of scp-3467 94 into human societies this
includes all recreational activities
relating to forms of media used to
convey information such as films and
books must have scrambled text or speech
no nonfiction media may be introduced to
SCP 39 94 under any circumstances no
information regarding the personal lives
of personnel may be mentioned under any
circumstances incident log 9 on
September 16th a breach was attempted by
14 a category instances 37 B category
instances and 6 C category instances dr.
Kaufman and 4 accompanying security
guards approached SCP 3990 force
containment chamber which caused the
affer mentioned instances to swarm
around the door it should be noted that
this behavior is that normal for a C P
39
for dr. Kaufman opened the door and four
security guards were promptly trampled
by the offending instances however all
instances wall around dr. Kaufman who
headed in the opposite direction from
the group until he was subsequently
apprehended 11 minutes after the breach
the instance is managed to reach the
center of site 92 before all were
successfully terminated via a contained
flood of 20,000 gallons of battery grade
sulfuric acid interview log 7
interviewed dr. Kaufman interviewer
forward the following interview occurred
immediately after incident log 9
September 16th at the time of recording
dr. was the site director for site 92
playing log you were being swarmed by
SCP 39 94 container breach you just
under the door they were all over you
Kaufman in trouble the dogs and headed
straight for escape you forgot again I
apologize I only did what I could
excuse me Kaufman you can't keep them
here forever
I've taken the form of the dominant
species on planet and they're damn near
indestructible by our means of
measurement we haven't found them all we
don't know how many there are you don't
even know how they multiply they're not
here to discuss SCP 3990 for Kaufman we
aim to keep an army
these concrete walls and it won't do a
thing in your favor doctor they learn
and they keep advancing that's a simple
concept offers on their development will
stop working sooner or later but we
enough instances on this godforsaken
planet to teach them every language
under the Sun they'll learn the games
they'll know that humans don't actually
eat paste for breakfast or wear shoes on
their hands like he so desperately
wanted to believe soon enough they'll be
walking and talking like any other
person and at the rate they're going
there are smart us a million to one they
just keep going and going and going
you've wagered a have to bet against the
universe's greatest Conqueror doctor and
that's a bet you are going to lose
closing statement several hours
following the interview it was
discovered that dr. Kaufman had been on
vacation for the past two weeks
this kind of invasion of the Body
Snatcher vibes there huh anyway I think
that about does it for today by the way
um you like my new office
it's pretty cool right there's a little
nod to my old office back there anyway
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Boober MIT dread the reclusive
extrovert GM's Sabha arbiter soul
Darius Tom Justin day Oh philia gray
Durham Curie kuma and jayvo Jack
Jonathan Augusto Joseph Lewis su Qing
modding and dr. Proctor thank you all so
much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vulgar thank you
you